Many adults derive their meaning
in life from having
children, having families.
I don't have children.
So it's been very important to
find or even impose
meaning on my life.
I call the MDMA, the
chemical of connection.
This medicine encourages you to reach
out and figuratively or
literally touch another person
and deepen that connection.
And that's been very meaningful to me.
Better things for better living
Through chemistry for...
Better living through chemistry
was the official slogan
of DuPont chemicals for decades.
It became the ironic cri de
coeur of counterculture hippies
in the 1960s, who started to experiment
with psychedelic drugs,
ranging from LSD to Mescalin
to magic mushrooms.
One of those old hippies
is Charley Wininger,
a 71 year old Brooklyn-based
psychotherapist
and relationship specialist
who New York Newsday once
dubbed "The Love Doctor"
Wininger has recently come out
of what he calls "the chemical closet"
with his new book 'Listening to Ecstasy:
The Transformative Power of MDMA'
which is both a how-to
guide and memoir of how
this drug impacted his relationship
with his wife, Shelley, a retired nurse
In 2000, she was out
of a bad marriage, a repressive marriage
and she wanted to spread
her wings and fly.
And she learned that I was a psychonaut,
one who does psychedelics.
And this book is largely about our story
and how MDMA can really be used
as emotional super glue for relationships
and added a whole other layer
of intimacy and closeness for us.
Wininger's on the forefront
of a psychedelic Renaissance,
that consciously builds
on the lessons of the
1960s to deliver not just
more effective therapy, but
what he calls "serious fun."
Fritz Perls famously said,
lose your mind and come
to your senses.
When I'm high on MDMA,
my mind quiets down,
And I feel my heart and I
feel this central aliveness,
this, this chemical
affirmation of my spirit.
And it's like, the sun
itself is rising in my heart.
It's like taking a chemical
helicopter ride above my life.
And I could look out at
where I've been, where I am
in my life and perhaps to
the horizon where I wanna go.
And then I can come back down
and rededicate myself to the
way that I want to be living.
MDMA was first synthesized
by pharmaceutical giant,
Merck back in 1912 and
rediscovered decades later
in the mid 1960s by Maverick
chemist, Alexander Shulgin
who liked its ability to
increase emotions and empathy
among users.
Therapists started using it
in counseling sessions, but
after it gained a reputation
as a party and rave drug,
it was banned by the Drug
Enforcement Administration
in 1985.
Thanks to the decades long efforts
of the Multidisciplinary Association
for Psychedelic Studies or M.A.P.S.
MDMA assisted psychotherapy is now
at stage three clinical
trials for FDA approval.
If the experience of
marijuana is any indication,
medical use could eventually
lead to the legalization
of MDMA for recreational
purposes, as well.
As befits both a tribal elder
and a medical professional,
Wininger stresses the intentional use
of drugs, as a means to an end.
In the psychedelic community
there's an emphasis
on integrating psychedelic experiences,
that is learning to
turn states into traits,
learning to turn the
experience of, for example
a good MDMA high to translate that
into your life and bring it
into your life in a sober way
because we spend most of
our times, hopefully, sober.
It's taken a long time
for the culture to largely
forget the polarization
and violent polarization that happened
in the sixties and early seventies and
and have that generation
gap reduced and have traumas
like the Vietnam war become a memory
so that psychedelics can now re-emerge
in using the medical
model as a healing force
in a time when we need healing very much.
As psychedelics become more
mainstream and people realize
that they can use it to
restore the lost part
of their relationship.
Or they can use it to build
upon a good relationship.
They could use it to, we
call it recreational use.
I prefer the term celebrational use
Even as Wininger says that
MDMA and other substances
can help shrink the gap
between generations,
he also underscores that people's needs
and bodies change with age
Past the age of 35 or 40,
the way to keep a happy,
long-term relationship
with these wonderful
medicines is to not abuse them
which takes some discipline
because the experience can be so good
that you wanna do it again and again,
but I limited to four five times a year.
That way I could keep
it up into my seventies.
So we plan these things very carefully
and it gives us so much to
look forward to in life.